[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
players all over the world have
struggled to earn the Grandmaster title
which players will earn uh norm which
players will go home with the prize
welcome to the 2018 st. Louis norm
Congress
[Music]
hello just fans and welcome back to st.
Louis for the 2018 st. Louis norm
Congress the Grand Master and
International Master norm tournaments
I'm Ben Simon along with Grand Master
Josh Friedel were here for round number
two and round number one last night man
blood on the board all over the place
nine out of ten distinct decisive
results it was quite something to watch
it really was and we have we're gonna
have the recap of round one we're gonna
look at the live games being played
right now in round two but about norms
if you're hearing about this for the
very first time it can be kind of
confusing the gist of it is a norm is a
performance that you have in a
tournament a very strong performance
above a certain rating and it's all
decided by mathematics of course we'll
get to it later on but if you have three
grandmaster norms that is three superior
tournament performances with other
grandmasters then you get another notch
in your belt a norm toward becoming a
grandmaster and the same goes with the
International Master title which is one
step below so we'll see who gets those
doctorates or the steps toward the
doctorates of chess but we have already
seen some games being played last night
let's take a look at who's playing in
this tournament first in the Grandmaster
norm section itself now this is the top
section we have international players
all over the place that is certainly
required in a norm tournament to
guarantee every player who is not a
grandmaster the chance to get a norm
Josh it's a strong field it certainly is
it's not only strong it's really diverse
you notice how there's a lot of us
players most of whom were familiar with
but then there's a Boros from Hungary
actually moves in st. Louis however you
have verano of you have Hamra cool of
you have so so lucky to who are from
Greek Ukraine Uzbekistan and Greece and
completely unknown players to most of us
and you know look forward to seeing how
they do and how they
America's most like we said yesterday
this tournament is a big chance for us
to meet some of those new players these
events are the first time we hear these
up-and-comer names and we look forward
to seeing more of them now there's also
an international master norm section
let's take a look at the roster in that
now ten players we have three
international masters in this section
three of the four top places now this
screen is organized by rating we haven't
gotten to the standings yet so this is
simply by rating going into it sir game
at senko the top player if you combine
both of the fields highest rated player
in both builds and in this field the
highest rated by quite a bit so I'll be
interested to see whether he dominates
the field or whether he's tripped up by
some of these young players Josh how
does that happen how was he just an
international master and he has that
really high rating I've seen this happen
with Russian players in particular and
with certain Federation's because you
have to actually apply for your title
they don't just give it automatically
put a wand you know Knight you or
whatever they you know you have to
actually apply for it send it in and I
think some Federation's don't do that as
much I remember the player of e2 gov
who's now at 2700 plus GM I saw him I
think he was an FM in the high 2600 oh
my god and it's like come on guys just
give him this title please that's an
extreme example you're extremely sample
but it does happen and I'm sure he's met
the requirements and he'll probably get
awarded it pretty soon no probably just
had it I'm gonna have to check on this I
was told in passing by an arbiter that
there is a GM elect in one of the fields
I'm gonna have to double-check who that
is I did not I do not have that on my
information sheet right here it might be
him I don't know it's like hopefully so
our tournament format consists of 210
player round robins with the players we
just saw the time control is game in 90
minutes 90 minutes for each player base
time with a 30-second increment from
from move number one so the 30 seconds
will add up because of that the players
are required to take notation the entire
length of the game you know sometimes
you see in time controls where you have
less than five minutes left you don't
have to take notation anymore
it's not the case in this event it's not
the case whenever this increment that's
not the case it's only the case when
it's a five-second play increment can
lull you to sleep though because you
think 30 seconds I can get low on time a
lot of people are habitual time trouble
is I'll try not to mention too many
names but they get really low and they
think ah the increment I'm fine because
I can build up time but once you get low
in this time control you don't get a
second time control you don't get an
extra 30 minutes you don't get an extra
hour so you get low you're gonna be
playing quick the rest of the game and
not everyone's happy with that situation
and if you're in a complex game that can
be doubly bad well it happened in the
last couple of years I think there was a
game with Magnus Carlsen where he
thought there was a second time control
what happened 40 and there wasn't I'd
like to say grandmasters are super
professional at knowing the time
controls of each event and doing all
that but I would say that if anything
they're more lazy and at times they
don't know the event so they don't know
the time controls they don't know the
round times it's it's almost
embarrassing so I would not surprise me
let's see if any of these players will
have it embarrassed
hopefully not for their sake we don't
need more excitement they're already
good it's the exciting for us right
let's take a look at the schedule this
schedule it's a little odd we have two
rounds some of these days the first
round was last night we're gonna have
two rounds on Friday Saturday and Sunday
and the times you need to remember are
11 a.m. Central Time and 5 p.m. central
time these players are going to be
playing two games a day in most cases on
Monday and Tuesday and 11 a.m. both days
will have the penultimate and the final
rounds respectively those will be
important rounds indeed they certainly
will and if these players actually get
the opposite of what most working people
do Friday Saturday and Sunday they're
working hard they kind of get it to take
it a little easier on Monday and Tuesday
but I think as I mentioned in our intro
those can be dangerous rounds because
you get one round today you think it's
easier your brain kind of lays off chess
and it can work against you so we'll see
how they do those two rounds but I'm
guessing the players will be happy to
have a slight break for after the eighth
round the nine-to-five
office world is having their Friday but
this is just our Tuesday the week is
just beginning fans ok let's take a look
at the results from last night our first
round was played we were not live on the
air but
you must have seen the action at us
chess champs calm the games were in the
chest 24 module a great way to watch a
chess and a lot of action that was there
was oh my god blood on the board Josh
what do you think of this round it was a
really interesting round I thought that
all the games could have been decisive
or many games could have been drawn for
example the chamber to 2gm jacques
chandra and mark paraguay could have
easily been a win for oxide he blundered
upon at the last minute and enabled
Paraguay to snag the draw whereas comer
Akula Vince Bartholomew I thought was
going to be a draw for most of the game
but at the very end
karma cool of really played some very
accurate chess put pressure on John and
John was not able to hold the position
so back that could have gone either way
a lot of the other games were fairly
insane so you know it was quite
something just fairly insane fairly
insane yeah I should point out that
Seoul Aikido did win her game against
top patel right in there so just letting
people know that Patel did not would not
oh there was a yeah yeah okay well we'll
have to look into that now let's take a
look at the results for the
International master norms section in
round one and just like the the red on
the screen Jos a lot of blood on the
boards there certainly was and I think
red is gonna be the colour for this
event because I'm guessing there's gonna
be lots of rounds lots of blood and that
does not say anything bad about the
players they're fighting they're trying
to do that they're trying to create nice
results and honestly it's a treat for us
to watch especially with so many young
players in this event again Justin
weighing only 12 a couple others who are
14 15 it's a young event
apart from also tantal turgut as we
mentioned in his 50s but still playing
good Justin actually got a very nice win
against Jacobsen the cardiologist chess
player indeed well Josh why is it that
when we have like the super strong
tournaments like the seek field Cup and
the London Classic and all of the other
classical events whenever those top 10
players play each other there are a lot
more likely to draw than these players
they certainly are and there are lots of
reasons for that I think partially
they're really well-prepared especially
in the opening so a lot of the times the
position that gets out of the opening is
just not much or barely some little
teeny advantage to work with and they're
all excellent defenders so it takes a
lot for them to win games and they're
playing at a high level they're playing
at a higher level than these players
nothing these players aren't very strong
but it just makes it very difficult to
win games or as these players the
openings tend to be more varied a lot of
them play more aggressively you see more
mistakes and therefore you see more back
and forth results I don't think either
is bad I like to watch both but honestly
sometimes it's nice to get a break from
the elite players and watch these guys
really slug it out indeed and going into
today we you know it's anybody's chess
tournament of course but let's take a
look at the standings coming into the
day after just one round for the Grand
Master norm section all right
Pablo Vorontsov camera cool uh Dennis
poros so like he do with one point but
you know everyone's so close this really
can't be taken too seriously at this
point it's not indicative of how the
tournament gonna be necessarily I mean
again I mentioned the other day that
it's important to get off to a good
start and believe me winning that first
game can definitely propel you to a good
tournament but it doesn't always mean
anything even in the elite events I
remember one Sinquefield Cup I believe
it was where two polyp on the first two
games and ended up only finishing in the
middle of the pack so in these events
I'd say it's even more likely that could
happen so it's nice to get off to that
first win kind of terrible to lose the
first game but at the same time they
have plenty of room to come back and
you're just gonna see ones and zeroes
whatever we take a look at our next
standing the International master norm
section look at that yeah not a lot of
draws on that game not a lot huh not too
many zero yes and plenty of interesting
games Matt saenko proving his ratings so
far but at the same time again just one
round you don't really know what's going
on and yeah just a lot all pretty much
all interesting games very few of them
were one-sided almost all of them the
other player could have drawn or maybe
even won the game as well so certainly
not you know the result did not have to
happen this way and
we're talking about norms a lot six or
six and a half in most cases we'll get
you the norm it really depends on the
player but if we're a couple rounds from
the end of this thing and we know that
nobody can norm there's no problem there
because they still can go home with
prizes we have a prize fund here let's
take a look at the prizes for the grand
master norm section ooh what a lucrative
event this is Josh not bad and
especially Norma vents tend to have
lower prices than regular events because
people are playing for norms but often
times you actually have to pay to play
in a normal event these players actually
get to compete for a pretty nice prize
fund and at least get their expenses
paid for so it's a pretty good deal and
also the International master norms
section has its own prize fun not too
shabby itself they're definitely not up
to 1200 hours there you see a nice live
shot there from one of our cameras in
our board room at the st. Louis chess
club the world-famous st. Louis chess
club both fields are being played there
you see international arbiter Tony rich
who's actually the deputy arbiter for
this event he is but he's clearly you
know holding his end up there doing the
work making sure the players are good or
maybe he's just taking a walk you know
maybe just take it away yeah so we have
the pairings for round number two the
round that's currently underway and I
know that we have a result or two in
Josh I haven't been able to glance but
going into the round last I checked
there was one result which was mark
Parag WA defeated Daniel gray which we
choose for Parag WA he drew his first
game so now he's off to one and a half
out of two whereas gurevich lost the
tough game last night
to hammer a cool so he's now at o + 2
which means it's in order to get a
grandmaster norm he's got to get six and
a half out of seven that's a tall order
against such a strong field it sure is
and here these are the games that are
happening right now at us chess champs
calm board number five that will be our
game of the day as hammer cool-off takes
on Sol Aikido and this is just on paper
first of all the game of the day because
both players won their games last night
so I mean if someone wins again you're
suddenly to it oh you're two and oh and
they're both playing for Grandma
Norm's so two-and-oh is an awfully good
start it's hard to get six-and-a-half in
a field like this but if you start out
to know needless to say your chances go
up and last I looked so lucky who
actually had a pretty good position as
black so I but it's an interesting game
it's really double edged and I look
forward to looking at it I can't wait to
look at that in just a few moments here
but the pairings right now also going on
for the International Master norm
section here they are and I don't we
don't have any results there do we Josh
not that I'm not that I saw last no okay
and I know that Verbinski had a big edge
up on Brandon Jacobson who seems to be
having a tough day but all the other
games they're still in progress and the
game of the day there definitely has to
be sir game at Cinco and Josh colas oh
for sure and I should correct myself I
noticed that Torres and Chi you did
agree to a draw in their position so
there is one result okay and there we
have the game of the day in this section
for sure yes ain't going close I mean
this is Matt's anko's tournament to win
if he doesn't win it's gotta be a
disappointment right first all right
honestly he's probably not only wants to
win he wants to get like seven and a
nine maybe even better because if he
gets if he wins the torrent was six and
a half he probably still doesn't perform
his rating I don't know if that's quite
true but I mean at least I'd say at
least six and a half would be the score
he'd be satisfied with and colos lost
the topsy-turvy or sorry one of
topsy-turvy game last night which he
easily could have lost so if he couldn't
keep his result going and make that
result count you know it's not always
about like how you get the win if you
get the win you're usually pretty happy
and if you can keep that result going
it's pretty good so if he can hold the
draw in that game I think he'll be
pretty happy with its chances well chess
fans we are definitely happy to be here
with you as a nice friend to walk you
through this tournament at us chess
champs calm so open those games up Josh
let's go around the horn and take a look
at the games well the first game I'd
like to look at is camera cool up
against solar Keaton really interesting
game as you can see Black's up in
exchange why it's Kings a little iffy I
think that solo Quito has an excellent
chance to win this game but let's take a
look at how this happened because this
came from quite an interesting opening
Hamrick who loves white so lucky news
black both won their first game so at
first I thought the game was gonna be
quiet this is a known quiet lime white
can play Queen c2 Queen b3 g3 usually
it's slow but White's decided psyche I'm
gonna play carnage of course this isn't
known this is a known way to play it's
not like this has never been played
before or anything like that oftentimes
black usually doesn't want to take this
pawn because rook g1 the g7 pawn gets
hit
not exactly a fun time d5 is kind of the
move I like in general ponent players on
the side I like to play in the center
but she chose to castle which of course
is also fine white plays g5 black plays
98 so this 98 is a bit of a sad piece
but it's unclear whether g4 g5 is ever
going to be good it could backfire very
easily your kid could become weak and
we'll see how opening the board there
does backfire on him later they develop
their pieces in a relatively normal
manner I'd say Bishop g2 Queen c2 both
sides are just trying to get out h4
becomes necessary to make sure this g5
pawn stays guarded sometimes you might
want to play h5 g6 she plays f5 which is
an interesting decision trying to block
off the Queen
a typical defensive type move white
doesn't really want to take because that
would bring the knight into the game and
fix her main problem with the position
so he and said castles she plays a 5
very aggressive trying to maybe push
these pawns give herself a little extra
room III he plays d6 d3 it should be 6
so both sides are developing relatively
normally but I would say that honestly
with these pawns here
White's the one with something to prove
and if white doesn't prove anything this
could become problematic Bishop d2 Queen
d7 king h2 this move is a little funny
but I think the idea is he was worried
about f4 and the bishop coming to age 3
so he wanted to stop it
this move looks a little suspicious to
me but we'll see how it happens she
plays rook b8 I'm guessing just a slight
improvement maybe a6 b5 in some
positions rook d1 a6 Bishop back to c1
it looks a little strange to play this
way but the idea is he wants the option
of d4 maybe
get is the bishop on g2 wasn't doing
much anyway Queen to f7 rook to g1 this
this looks a little suspicious
usually you allow something like this
some bad things can happen but the game
changed quite dramatically so she took
it looks a little strange to give up the
bishop for the night but the night
controls this important d5 square the
bishop is kind of blocked by all the
pawns anyway pawn takes
I thought Queen takes looked a little
bit more normal but it could be there
are some concrete problems Queen to h5
I'd be a little scared I don't know
about you Ben looks scary I I would be
like rook h1 get me out get me out but
he played Bishop h1 again this is I
would be a little frightened here but
these players are clearly braver than I
am so 97 she maneuvers in Knight to g6
attacking this pawn it looks just bad to
me and he pitches the pawn she doesn't
even take it she plays f4 continuing to
play aggressively takes half for Bishop
g4 and this was a key moment pinning
this Knight
you really can't save it without sacking
the exchange so he played Queen e2 first
she took on h4 again notice the killer
pin got to give up that rook now at the
end of all this throws in the bishop
check you get this interesting position
she's won in exchange but as we know the
exchange is not always so easy to win
with sometimes you're up in exchange but
the bishops prove stronger than the
rooks I don't think that's gonna happen
for him here this bishop is a really
great piece but it's just one piece all
she has to do is fix this knight bring
this rook into the game White's Kings a
little weak I would say that she's in
good shape f takes e5 was played Knight
c7 a move I like getting that night off
the back rank threatening the bishop so
for example taking this pawn would be a
pretty questionable decision allowing
mates not something I would recommend so
he retreats
she plays 96 and let us see if there
have been moves played since
there have been quite a few moves played
since this was last I saw it let's see
what happened King G - so trying to play
rook H one she checks on f4 note how
taking this pawn would probably be a
mistake due to rook a chuan and this
Queen is actually trapped rook takes f2
Queen takes f2 it doesn't really save
you so this could have been a little bit
dangerous so she gave a check forcing
the bishop to take the knight and once
you lose the two bishops I think it
becomes a lot harder so rook h1 she
takes g5 with check saves her H pawn I'd
say it's pretty bad news for white takes
on d6 rook f8 doubling you may not try
to take this pawn just yet but it's
always under attack now white plays rook
F h2 Queen e5 d pawns weak
C pawns weak he tries to take on b7
which is understandable sometimes when
you have a bad position you have to just
try to take pawns whenever you can even
if it looks dangerous
she illuminates the d6 pawn and then
comes in and this was the drawback to
taking this b7 pawn that now this rook
comes in again I understand the decision
but it looks quite nasty
so check and this is where we have it
white played King f2 and she played
Queen to b8 so she's covering Queen e8
check you would not want to allow that
in a lot of situations although for the
moment the rook can come back and I
would say this is close to resign able
the rook b2 is a huge threat pinning the
Queen I'm not exactly sure what White's
gonna do to save himself here this looks
quite nasty
14 minutes left on the clock for so
lucky too but only four and a half yeah
hammer who love and it was a complex
position it's understandable but
honestly I'm really unsure what's gonna
happen so I mean this rupee to check
moves just the killer
I thought maybe King III was the best
shot trying to at least save this King
but honestly I just don't believe in
this one bit there has to be a way to
break through it could be something as
simple as moving this rook back but the
idea of King III is just to play Bishop
before and kind of hold on in the center
and pray that nothing horrible happens
to you but honestly there's no Connor
plate here the King is weak I think that
Seoul Aikido is gonna get our second one
well it looks like hammer who love is
just made of move he is indeed played
King III let me check actually no Queen
B at King III is uh right so I don't I
don't see it on the board yet but I'm
guessing King III you'll be played just
cuz I don't see what else is it gonna be
done yeah you have to watch out rook h6
check there's no perpetual but as long
as she controls the c5 square there's no
issue so I would say it's uh again
pretty much I think blacks Pennell just
win this game the young lady from table
Greece stavroula soul Aikido are you
familiar with her I'm not at all
actually
me neither she's definitely one of the
newcomers a very friendly person I'd
love to get her in here too for an
interview at post game
she's definitely the game of the day
here I mean I would say so I mean she
gets to to know and his black she gets a
win against one of the very very high
rated opponents so so what's going on in
some of the other games well I figured
we could go to the I am norm section and
check out there was a game there's a
game here mat Senko against Josh colas
because this game is extremely crucial
for the standings as we discussed and
this is a game where again matsuhiko is
the much higher rated player I think he
out rates colas by almost 300 points
yeah more than 300 points so anyway yeah
350 350 points is white so not winning
this game
to say it would be a disappointment for
him and I don't know I mean it's one of
those it's a king of pawn endgame which
means it's concrete it's you have to
calculate it out and I'm not totally
sure but to me it looks like a draw I'm
guessing in this position white plays
out for King takes up five King here I
would imagine the King has to move back
white plays up here and now at the very
least I think f5 checks should do the
trick
if King d4 came back King here King back
there's no reason why either side should
be winning here oh yeah to my knowledge
so what's this game always like this no
it wasn't so let's actually go back so
we can start at the beginning 9f 3906 a
lot of 9f trees you know as bloody as
this tournaments been usually bloody
tournaments don't have Knight f3 c4 to
begin you know usually it's more more
and more sharper starts but okay
Catalan so Josh close does something
which I don't like as much in the
opening in this position usually have
two choices you either play Bishop e7
and Castle with the idea that you later
take on c4 or you take immediately with
the idea that if usually white will play
Queen a4 check you have an option you
can play c6 b5 you can play an AP d7 and
try to a 6 b5 and you get a Catalan type
position without what's pawn on d4 kind
of a quiet system he plays Bishop e7 and
then takes and this allows Matt Cinco to
my opinion just get a comfortable
advantage he plays Knight a3 now you can
take this Knight but then the problem is
you lost the tempo of Bishop e7 and that
I tell a whole tempo was a lot so white
can take just take back and even in a
position like that just shook hands they
draw yeah I think O's got to be
disappointed with that result I would
say but again nice nice safe from Josh
kolja so in my opinion had a had a tough
game I can fast forward a little bit to
where that happens so he call us chose
not to play this and it looks fairly
safe for black but honestly this Bishop
on g2 against this Bishop on c8 it's
just just a nice advantage for white I
believe typical Catalan advantage and
they ended up getting into a position
where they trade a bunch of pieces he
did get his bishop
but after all these trades he has to
allow bishop takes f6 and he has a weak
King now the weak King by itself not
always such a big deal
sometimes these double pawns aren't so
much if the Queen's ever trade it's just
basically nothing but I think in this
position white is the one who's having
fun White's in the driver's seat I
thought you should play just rook see
one very simple attacking the Queen if
the Queen tries to hide out over on the
Queen side you can maybe plan sorry on
the Kings side you could play on the
Queen side if the Queen drops back then
you try to attack the King so you kind
of tease both sides you threatened to
attack the Kings side if Black gets too
defensive you switch to the other side
of the board and that's kind of how you
play these positions but it's very
always very close to just being drawn
and I think that call us played pretty
nicely this kind of sat doubled his
rooks and again I thought that white was
a little more comfortable but he wasn't
really able to do too much they got this
position and you can see here that Motte
Sanko actually chose to trade and I'm
guessing he just didn't really see an
alternative keep in mind if he allows
Queen d5 check Queen D 1 check Queen d5
and it trades to a rook endgame most
likely a lot of them will be drawn so
unless he can win a pawn the rook end
games are very Jewish so they got here
and I thought that this would actually
be a simple draw but when I played
through it a little bit more I saw that
White's Queen got to f6 like this and I
thought that if the King moved back this
H pawn was coming up maybe some slight
chances but ultimately it's still very
close to a draw this did indeed happen
but colas played Queen a5 and it's one
of those where you allowed the double
pawns in the king of pawning game but
apparently he calculated it out I
haven't seen it yet so I don't know if
this was all perfectly played but
apparently h6 and the doubled pawns are
just not important enough here the key
is that you have spare moves and in this
position black has King e6 King f6 the
end of time and as long as you have
those spare moves it's going to be kind
of difficult for your opponent
too much if he can get f3g 4g5 and get
that outside h pond he's gonna have
winning chances but apparently this was
not the case
he played G for what else and black
played f6 this is kind of clever because
if you did takes maybe this would still
be a draw but now you have a much more
challenging situation if f6 you go here
King e7 you have to watch out for this
move you have to watch out for this move
I actually don't see a win here but this
is at least more dangerous perhaps he
chose f6 allowing this capture but
notice how your extra pawn is just not
useful black as the better king so he
could try to chase this pawn but my
suspicion is that this would have been a
little bit dangerous
you can play king e4 King d5 King e6 and
note that white Queens will check so
gets an extra move can take this pawn
probably no reason to go for this for
Josh so he just played king e5 and took
this pawn and I didn't see the very end
of the game ah he didn't even take the
pawn he just play King D 5 and they
agree to a draw and that's certainly
good enough the pawn doesn't mean
anything here if king d3 you just go
back anywhere and the problem is you
just sit between these two squares dead
drop there's no break through so he
defended a top position very well and
probably not saenko didn't use the most
of his chances but again tricky in those
positions you like to press you want to
press a long time but ultimately one
little slip you don't really have too
much indeed Josh colas sits with two
international master norms and one
grandmaster norm which you pointed out
yesterday is a token Tony it certainly
does count um unless they've changed the
rules very recently keep in mind I
pursued my titles about 10 years ago but
sometimes yes sometimes the club like
but I've had students who have been
pursuing them so yeah the Grandmaster
norm does count towards or not is in I
am wrong it would be silly for it not to
if you think about it so he has his
norms he just needs to get to that
twenty four hundred feet a mark a couple
years ago he was very close I think he
got the 23d or there abouts but he fell
off he had a couple bad events but if
he's on the upswing again
and he's that strength I could see him
getting to 2,400 and probably beyond so
we'll see how he does
impressive Josh colas you know we met
him a couple years ago at the Junior
Champion oh yeah yeah very fine young
man 19 years old it was in st. Louis now
yep
so uh what else is going on this current
round round number two uh let me take a
look so there was this game between
Torres and Chi Yu that drew just to show
you it was kind of the only tame game
we've had so far
so I can show you very quickly it was an
Enzo Indian played Queen c2 NIM zone so
they played down this very classic main
line but there were a few interesting
moments so they get to this position
rook c8 this move will look weird to
people who never seen these kind of
moves before but tune in so players this
is a perfectly normal move the idea is
you want to play see five and take back
with the rook to keep things fluid to
make this Queen uncomfortable and to
make sure this night stays guarding this
night so it's a very common idea and if
white castles which looks like a normal
move black can say hello fork the bishop
and Queen and the key here is that
you're attacking this Bishop which means
that White has to recapture black
recaptures blacks doing quite well in
this endgame probably a little better
even so a normal move like castles it
can actually end up in a worse position
which means you got to stay on your toes
from the very opening something a lot of
players forget white played Bishop f4 c5
castles and this was another moment
which I thought was kind of interesting
because I thought that white could
actually try even before c4 maybe 94
here actually didn't look unplayable to
me with the idea that if the Queen goes
back and that was idea of Bishop h4 by
the way that now the bishops defended I
didn't think this was all that easy and
to be quite honest I'd be a little a
little worried here is white in some
positions f4 is always on the loose a
very typical idea I thought this was
quite interesting and of course white
could try to take this Queen now
but after takes I didn't really see too
much I thought why could try here but
honestly that's kind of a end of it
because if you take d6 I think you too
so I thought that this was probably a
decent choice for black but she chose c5
castles and honestly I thought the
Taurus had the slight advantage the
thing is he does have the two bishops
early the game has been drawn it has
been drum so we'll check out just to the
ends I thought that here white add maybe
some chances for advantage but
apparently she snuffed it out again
looks like a very delicate situation the
queen and rook are lined up the ship g3
is almost there but this Knight kind of
can take care of everything
maybe he just couldn't find much so
Queen e2 Knight f6 and here they
actually had a funny perpetual so Knight
b5 if you take the rook the Queen hangs
Queen c6
taking a seven looks absurdly dangerous
so it was not played they went back and
apparently white just couldn't find
anything so he decided to call it a day
get some rest for the next round a lot
of players like to do this on double
round days just because two rounds of
nasal tough one if you get a little bit
of rest for the next round
it might work in your favor you've
really got to figure out where to call
your shots and if you really do I mean
I'm sure he's disappointed not to get
more chances as white in this game but
honestly he's one of the im's he's not
playing for a norm he doesn't have to
score an outrageous in a lot of points
he probably just wants the rest cheers
oh is the former Canadian Women's
Champion won that title a couple of
years ago and she is uh from Ottawa so
first time that I have seen she you
enjoy today gets a draw with black
against Luis Torres and that's a good
result she lost the tough one to might
Sankoh yesterday so she's probably glad
to right the ship get a solid draw his
black against the tough player actually
very interesting I talked to her for the
first time recently and apparently she
lived in Finland for many years so she
actually speaks Finnish in addition to
English and Mandarin so yeah world
travelers indeed there's a really cool
game going on between turgut and vanilla
so this game I have no idea what on
earth happened
because I thought the target had an
excellent position and now I see he's
down a queen and maybe he's somehow
magically alright down a queen but I
kind of doubt it
so let's see how on earth this happened
because I saw it we don't have to go
through the whole thing it was a it was
a semi Slav and I thought that bonala
played a very dangerous move which I
thought was instructive he played g3 now
g3 looks kind of normal you want to play
Knight h4 and support your knight
threatened a g6 but when I see this move
and I see this bishop I get nervous it's
just not something I'd like to do unless
I really feel like I have to obviously
it's a move sometimes you just play but
I really think it backfired on him rook
fv8 was played Bishop c2 c5 and here I
really thought Joel should have you know
been like you know what I need to make
sure I'm not worse put the pawn on d5 to
kill this bishop probably about equal I
don't think this past pawn such a big
deal but honestly I would have played it
safe here but Joel was like nope
and honestly here I thought that his
position was very dangerous I see this
bishop I see danger so this all happens
Knight - G - he played h6 very
aggressive move Knight g4 f5 yeah
these gave us over Toni Rich's declaring
a yellow I would imagine that white won
this game yeah so we'll get to the end
of the game in a minute but yeah h3
Knight back to f6 and it could be he
just backfired you know he had a nice
position but he went a little too hog
wild sometimes that happens you like
your position a little too much trying
to play too aggressively it backfires on
you but somehow Joel won a queen here as
white so f 4e 5 yeah allowing f-35 is
not ideal a knight takes g6 quite a shot
the ideas of King takes there's queen g4
action with this guy hanging and if the
Queen takes this Bishop hangs so
turgut's like have a look Joel says no
thank you I'm keeping you away from this
h3 point obviously allowing a sac there
could end up in meat so rook takes
Knight
and sometimes this is just what you do
when your position your field is tough
it's difficult you just kind of start
sacking away and hope for the best but
apparently it didn't really work out
Joel takes way too much material h3 is
covered he sacks the Queen for one last
try but the problem is this bishop this
rook just doesn't have any we're good to
go
this bishop hangs with check and it's
just too much notice how if rook takes
g4 this still hangs with check so it
goes back and then he resigned after
rook d1 rook takes g4 the ideas if takes
this rook you can probably check here as
well but you can even just take this
bishop just very simple there's no maid
of course and after rook takes d4 rook
takes d5 check that was the end of that
so kind of a disappointing end I thought
that torger could have maybe gotten two
out of two but instead he's an
aggression backfired on him only ended
up with one have you played either of
these men before
I've played Joel I think a couple times
I remember we had to draw in a
California tournament at some points and
tencel turgid actually played in a team
tournament in Chicago and I won his
black I remember that game i sacked in
exchange I was kind of an interesting
game but I thought he was a tough player
like he played very solid it took me a
while to kind of get the better of him
but he definitely wasn't enough solid
moved this game he was he was agro which
I like you know why not for sure Joe
Panora yeah one of my favorite
personalities who place in these
tournaments I really enjoy talking to
him at the last Invitational I believe
it was mm-hmm last year so yeah I've
known Joel a long time I actually went
the few the US chess school run by Greg
Johari which goes on each year the first
u.s. Jessica he was actually there as
was I so I remember him from all the way
back then I want to say was I mean 2007
or something or even before that it was
quite a ways back so I've known him
quite a lot well it's a I think we have
time for one more game okay and then we
have a special guest coming in to join
us from the world yes this guy's awesome
you wait too
I can't wait um let me see so let's see
we have a lot of a lot of craziness
going on crazy this is good job
we should I guess check out because we
we want to see Seoul Aikido did win ah
so we should we should definitely check
that one out okay I would happily are
gonna want to talk to stepper Elissa
lakitu absolutely I'd love to hear her
thoughts on this game and just in
general um because it was quite a game
so he did play King III followed my
suggestion which is usually not a good
sign
black played rook back to f8 which was
what I expected also predicting amazing
today D for this this was less expected
I feel like trying to push your bonds is
not the way to go here but at the same
time sometimes when you're losing you
just kind of play whatever I might have
tried rook to g2 but okay rookie a check
she played Bishop e4 takes d4 check and
this is the problem you're getting two
connected passers that's nice but your
king is just getting trashed so King
tasty if Vaughn takes d4 I believe he
was worried about this rook check the
King has to move here and then pins
everywhere just not pleasant
this isn't even a pin it's a check Josh
way to go
hey we sometimes forget sometimes forget
it's all the same yes
don't worry about it lessons from a
grandmaster so Queen b6 check King III
rook takes e4 check has to take with a
pawn if King takes I'd imagine there are
lots of wins but the easiest that I see
is rook e1 this is a pin and then this
is a secure look at that F takes e4 and
then Queen g3 check have to go up
because have to hang on to the rook rook
t1 check very nice move and that was the
end
the idea being of course if takes then
you skewer again making sure I'm getting
it right and if king c5 you play Queen
d6 me quite a crushing game and an
impressive performance to get to Toyota
- what's them was the mate actually
played on the board it was not played on
the board they resigned you always allow
me this is the general rule no one does
it this is proper etiquette you always
allow me if it's right away you don't
have to play off 20 moves to allow me
that's ridiculous but if there's matin
one if it's a nice meet in particular
this may it's okay he gets a pass but if
it's a really beautiful
me you must allow it I remember I had a
game against John lubic hammer that
Norwegian GM and he was just I had a
good position but I messed it up of
course and he was just killing me and he
thought I was resigning but I was
actually playing into a really beautiful
checkmate with two bishops well that was
very nice of you
yes it was he was like you're not
resigning very polite yes I'm a polite
person okay
well let's go into our first break here
in st. Louis for the dorm Congress when
we come back we will have one of our
special guests either one of the players
or the gentleman from the world chess
Hall of Fame Nick Schleicher I don't
think we've ever had on the air for one
of these live tournaments so it should
be a lot of fun I'm excited either way
absolutely okay we'll be right back
thank you for joining us here on chess
24 and us chess champs calm question on
Twitter from dem s I should not have
pronounced that that was a bit of a
champion
for those of you who are new to chess it
might look like VA 3 is an illegal move
here because white advances for two
squares not one but it still is
something we call hustle and you can do
that I have to do it instantly you can't
wait for a move like let's say play King
in seven kimchi - and I'll try because
[Music]
[Music]
I'll play for against Lawrence and now
he's going to play something against me
which we discussed at length during the
course of my steak yeah he told me this
is that g5 this was what I was kind of
hoping for because now I think the
farthest I know who Lawrence this is not
how chest works
certainly would be much much more
furniture such to work like this don't
think it does well maybe it does well
that's me regretting what I just said
how did I get from there to here is a
little bit beyond me and what's worse I
will never hear the end of my quality of
life has just gone downhill tremendously
because I'm actually sharing the office
of the guy
[Music]
[Music]
there's a weekend vacation in a nearby
city you be surprised be intrigued be
delighted the world chess Hall of Fame
in st. Louis is nothing you'd expect and
everything you love three galleries
highlight the history culture and
creativity behind the game explore chess
in ways you never imagined it's a
one-of-a-kind cultural institution where
rare artifacts and world-class art play
together the world chess Hall of Fame
mind art experience question on Twitter
from dem s I should not have pronounced
that that was a bit of a trap here
for those of you who are new to chess it
might look like ba3
is an illegal move here because white
advances pawn to square is not one but
it still is something we call hustle and
you can do that but you have to do it
instantly you can't wait for a move I
gotta say clanking in seven kimchi - and
I'll try because y'all played four
against Lawrence and now he's going to
play something against me which we
discussed the playing during the course
of my steak yeah he told me this is a g5
this was what I was kind of hoping for
because now I think the farthest I know
who Lawrence
this is not how chess works certainly
would be much much more fun if chess
actually work like this I don't think it
does well maybe it does well that's me
regretting what I just said how did I
get from there to here is a little bit
beyond me and what's worse I will never
hear the end of it my quality of life
has just gone downhill tremendously
because I'm actually sharing the office
of the guy
[Music]
you
[Music]
welcome back to the 2018 st. Louis norm
Congress right here in the chest capital
of the United States st. Louis Missouri
I'm Ben Simon alongside my good friend
sort of co-worker I guess a first-time
guests on a live tournament broadcast
exhibitions manager for the world chess
Hall of Fame Nick Schweiker Nick thank
you for being here thanks for having me
now you have one of the most interesting
jobs on the entire chess campus and
that's why I wanted to talk to you you
build walls you build these exhibits
basically from the ground up right yeah
I don't do most of the building anymore
but I do do the planning of the
exhibition layouts in conjunction with
the curators Shannon and Emily so how
did you get involved with the world
chess ala thing I went to art school and
they came back to st. Louis and was
looking for a job in the arts somehow
someone tipped me off to the Hall of
Fame being a young organization so I
applied as a gallery attendant and
worked my way up to preparator after
about six months and now I've been
exhibitions manager and I've been here
for close to five years and you weren't
a chess guy coming into this whole thing
no I mean I knew how to play chess but I
wasn't a chess guy well you know it's
good that the chess world hasn't driven
you crazy yet no I mean the chess
world's really exciting especially being
at the center of it all
so the Hall of Fame always has three
really cool exhibits going on with the
Hall of Fame itself on the very top
floor but then the other two floors are
just galleries tell us about the
exhibition's going on right now so the
typically the way the exhibition's are
laid out the first floor is more
contemporary art as it relates to chests
the second floor is more popular culture
as it relates to chess and the third
floor is like chess history specific
right now our first floor exhibition is
an exhibition of prints by Victor
Vasarely who was an OP artist he uses
patterns and kind of interesting
mathematical ways to kind of fool your
eye and he did a chess board
so we have the chess board on display as
well it's really cool so you can check
that out and the second floor exhibition
is a fashion exhibition right now called
pinned we had six designers design a
chess uniform and they had a competition
to see who came up with kind of the best
one and they
they were paired with grandmasters and
so they kind of told them what they like
and don't like about what they wear when
they're playing chess and what they kind
of want you know maybe a little more
mobility whenever they're moving around
so those designs are on display and that
exhibition was really cool because
there's the first time we did curved
walls Shannon came to me it was just
like hey I want curved walls in the
exhibition what can you do to pull this
off so Shannon Bailey of course is later
chief curator
she's the guiding mess of the ship and
we came up with a number of designs and
settled on these designs and kind of had
a construction company RJ Ross come in
and build the walls for us and it looks
beautiful and so then the third floor
exhibition is the Olympiad exhibition
Americans in the Olympiad so it's
focusing on the Americans participation
in the Chess Olympiad it's kind of
coming off of our big victory in 2016
2016 was an amazing year for us chess
the first year that the that Russia or
the we know back then it was the Soviet
Union then it was the first year that
they were involved in the Olympia that
we one goal in the first a mini decades
so it was very impressive in 2060 and
they got third right I believe so
probably yeah I think so I think you're
right there Blake yeah
and so those exhibitions are all up and
they're very exciting and so right now
we're working on plans for the spring
exhibitions first floor is going to be
an exhibition of chess sets from
pearling which is a luxury chess company
they make these kind of bespoke
fantastic chess sets so they've paired
with a number of artists to do chess
sets that are kind of hand-painted
handcrafted and so we're going to do an
exhibition of those there's gonna be a
cool VR set in there some neon chess
sets and some really cool kind of takes
on chess we're but a lot of them are
kind of rooted in the traditional kind
of chess boards second floor we're gonna
do a really really cool exhibition of
Staunton chess pieces we're working with
a couple collectors of Staunton chess
sets so that one's still in the works I
can't tell you too much about that and
our third floor is gonna be celebrating
10 years of the st. Louis chess club as
classics enter the scene field effect I
saw a little bit of a sneak preview I
anything but that looks like it might be
really cool that's gonna be really cool
it's gonna be nice to kind of step back
and I know I've only been here for six
of those years so stepping back and
seeing kind of what really has happened
to create st. Louis and put st. Louis on
the map as the center of the chess world
and those three exhibitions you're
talking about coming up are not too far
away in fact if you're interested in the
Victor Vasarely or the pin exhibits the
global moves Americans in chess
Olympiads exhibits
you should come really soon because you
only have a few weeks yeah they close
the end of March and the new shows are
opening April 12 just a couple days
before the US Championships that should
be really awesome and when people come
for the US Championships
I guess it's synched up on purpose right
because you have a lot of people out of
town coming to see these exhibits and
it's really cool to see what's going
into the Hall of Fame and Nick a lot of
people don't realize at art galleries at
museums there's a lot of hard work put
into these exhibits what are some of the
the hardest parts of the challenges of
your work I know you do a lot the
challenges are always creating something
new and exciting every exhibition we've
done has been radically different I mean
we don't have any kind of cookie cutter
exhibitions they're all new and they're
all challenging which is the fun part
because every six months you're learning
something new you're working with new
display methods new artworks new artists
and that's the funnest part as well as
the most challenging part well if you're
ever in st. Louis right across the
street from the Chess Club and
scholastic Center is the world chess
Hall of Fame there's really no place
like it Nick thank you for joining me
thanks for having me pleasure and let's
go to a break when we come back Josh
Reno will be back for more analysis
maybe even an interview
[Music]
the question on Twitter from dem s I
should not have pronounced that that was
a bit of a champion for those of you who
are new to chess it might look like VA 3
is an illegal move here because white
advances pawn to square is not one but
it still is something we call hustle and
you can do that but you have to do it
instantly you can't wait for a move I
can't say clicking in 17 G 2 and I'll
try because y'all play four against
Lawrence and now he's going to play
something against me which we discussed
at length during the course of my stay
yeah he told me this is that for g5 this
was what I was kind of hoping for
because now I think we practiced I know
who Lawrence this is not how it works
certainly would be much much more fun if
Chester G to work like this I don't
think it does
well maybe it does well that's me
regretting what I just said how did I
get from there to here is a little bit
beyond me and what's worse I will never
hear the end of it my quality of life
has just gone downhill tremendously
because I'm actually sharing the office
of the guy
[Music]
there's a weekend vacation on one tank
trip
[Music]
a moment comes in chess when you need to
test yourself at a different level chess
24 premium offers the tools that you
need to reach your maximum potential
from hundreds of interactive video
lessons to becoming part of the chess 24
community you can analyze with friends
or coach your students live you get
twenty four by seven coverage of chess
news and events access to premium
analysis and commentary and the chance
to interact with grandmasters and other
top players and coaches get it bashed
from the best and even challenge them to
a battle be the best chess player you
can be it's time to level up your game
with just 24 Premium Membership
[Music]
a moment comes in chess when you need to
test yourself at a different level chess
24 premium offers the tools that you
need to reach your maximum potential
from hundreds of interactive video
lessons to becoming part of the chess 24
community you can analyze with friends
or coach your students live you get
twenty four by seven coverage of chest
news and events access to premium
analysis and commentary and the chance
to interact with grandmasters and other
top players and coaches get it bashed
from the best and even challenge them to
a battle be the best chess player you
can be it's time to level up your game
with just twenty four premium membership
all right and we're back right here in
st. Louis for the 2018 norm Congress
Bensimon and Grand Master Josh Goodell
here with the calls and we have a result
in Josh we've had quite a few results in
in the GM room section we had John
Bartholomew draw against Pablo Vorontsov
we mentioned a performer Parag or beat
Daniel Gurevich Tata Bob raha me on just
be Grandmaster Akshat Chandra big wid
definitely a big win and there was a key
moment from that game I'd like to pull
up if we have a bit of time
Patel Boros is still going on Patel is
up a lot of pawns for an exchange so he
probably will have very good winning
chances and as we mentioned Rula already
won against camera cool yeah so in tot
Tubbs game there was this moment Tata
was down upon and on the attack pretty
much where she likes to be and at this
moment this was a really cool situation
where it looked like Chandra has a
really nice resource with rook t1 Akshar
I'm sure was maybe he already didn't
like his position but probably he was
defending on this resource from a long
time back but the way it often works and
these attacks is one resource can decide
whether it's good or bad and whether the
attack works or not and in this case
Tata has a really beautiful shot with 19
c5 check and again this is something
which if you don't plan in a while back
it's not so it's not such good news and
here I think there's just big problems
the king if it King moves anywhere it
gets checked by the Queen and harassed
pretty horribly and after 90 night which
is what he played Queen h5 check and you
have a beautiful double attack on the f7
King and the b1 rook she took one this
rook and took her a while but eventually
reeled in the point so a good recovery
from a pretty bad loss yesterday the
Boros oh yeah absolutely and Chandra
really is probably hurting a bit because
last night he probably should have
beaten paraguay and he only drew and now
that result is really biting him because
he's not
and obviously plenty of 20 minutes ago
but I'm sure that our shot is a bit
disappointed with his resolve
absolutely the former US Junior Champion
US Championship player one of the most
well known players around st. Louis
relocated here a year or two ago
so yes the option under it has to be a
little bit down on that but good for
Tata good for Tata and again I mean I'm
not sure for her like she's chasing a
grandmaster norm but her rating
obviously is way away she's still trying
to make the ring for her I am norm but
she's someone where she when she gets on
a roll she can win lots of games in a
row so she you know what that big win is
probably gonna be crucial for her and
we'll see if ox Ock can bounce back my
guess is I'm sure he can you know he's a
professional but not gonna be so easy
all right what else what else has
happened in this round
um so there have been some a lot of
action let's go actually to the so in
the I am norm we have this game this was
a really crazy game we're finally
Jacobson lost his black this was this
was pretty rough it was in the opening
just to play through it rather rather
briefly it was this line which has
become fashionable we're against the
Greenfeld you just fianchetto and it's
almost like coffeehouse chess is what it
looks like to me it's one of those
things where you would play it in blitz
but in real games you're like now play a
normal opening but now because computers
are telling us you know what some of
these coffeehouse systems are not so bad
you just put the bishop on h6 and say
well how are you gonna Castle bro you
know and it's kind of it's frustrating
it is frustrating right like you have to
deal with this so to my knowledge I
think their ideas with Queen AG Ford
Queen d6 in some positions and
possibilities like this in order to try
to do stuff but I that's not what black
chose and ultimately blacks King just
ended up under fire this all happened
b5 and here I thought he maybe had to
try I mean in this position rather like
98 is already kind of rough and here I
thought really he had to just try taking
97 Castle
just try to get out you know trying to
get out this is a little bit weak but he
played f6 which I thought was absurdly
risky and the king e7 and when I saw
King e7 I'm like men and sometimes it
happens you don't like your position so
you make extreme decisions sometimes
it's correct but other times I think
it's just too much and in this case I
think that the King on e7 is just a poor
piece I think his point was to defend
the Queen so that he could take this
pawn but honestly white has so many good
options here white took and these pawns
may look nice but with a king in the
center you never want to advance them
and white has ideas like f4 even here I
think f4 would have been a decent choice
instead he played rook d1 in 94 which I
thought was also kind of nice puts the
knight on d5 Bishop to g4 and blacks
King is just Airy for the rest of the
game the problem with King's like this
is there's no safety
you don't actually ever get to safety
you just have to hope you don't get made
it the whole game and it's hard to play
well and eventually he did wouldn't real
in the point in this position he won a
pawn I thought that black did a pretty
good job of actually getting his King
secured he has the center but honestly
he's still to open this rook side of the
game it's he has practical chances but
that's about it and eventually as we see
Queen e2 kind of a clever move pinning
this pawn with e4 ideas he has to make
sure these sacks don't work on f3 but my
guess would be that there's just nothing
here and again a little bit you know it
looks kind of nice but really you're not
doing much and eventually he the
position just gives out on him takes e5
I mean your position he lost down upon
and King his weekends he snuck an e4
pawn using this pin on the rook and then
brought the knight back and black
decided to understandably call it a day
so kind of a rough result for Brandon
who I believe is Owen to now so he's
gonna have some climbing back to do but
as we've seen in this event games go
both ways they're really volatile so he
could easily win the next two games you
know so we'll see how that goes
otherwise we already went over the draw
Justin wing has kind of an interesting
game going
he is black against Josiah Stearman and
this is pretty crazy honestly because
black has very dangerous looking pawns
white as dangerous looking prawns
there's an adage that all rook endings
are drawn well clearly they are not
talking about rook end games where both
sides have connected past punts then all
rook end memes are insane this is that
very same and here I don't know what to
tell you as far as what's going on
this requires lots of concrete
calculation I just looked at this
position but I would say honestly I just
don't know my guess would be somehow
this a pawn is just really annoying to
stop in general black has a couple extra
pawns for the moment maybe they don't
come into play maybe they do but I would
say that Justin is pushing for the win
here but at the same time anything can
happen in these end games usually what
matters more is not the pawn count but
how far advanced your pawns are the one
advantage desire has is both of his
pawns are pretty far advanced but I
would say that ultimately probably
Justin's the one trying to win Justin
Wang has won norm he earned that norm
last year in st. Louis so he already
knows how to get him norm here
and he's 12 he already knows how to get
in arms I didn't learn to get norms till
I was you know 17 I was a late bloomer
compared to him but see how it goes
I like Justin's trademark hand ah that's
that's a kid thing they do this now the
kids wear these hats they wear them low
sometimes their new hoodies Geoffrey
Zhang style yeah I'm telling you it's
scary it's kids are scary enough you
guys do not have to wear the hoods and
the caps just look normal you're scary
enough you do not need to scare us older
players anymore
it is our photographer Austin Fuller was
taking player portraits yesterday and
Justin showed up with his mother his mom
says you want to take the hat off for
the photo he said no they just took it
up with the hat on I said you know I
don't know that we've done that before
yeah it's very interesting but it's his
trademark you know that is Justin way
see one thing if I were a hat I just
look ridiculous
I still do it but I look ridiculous
Justin wing it's like a scary thing I
just I mean I'm frightened enough I used
to think of you as having
market I did it didn't become an it
became a trademark just cuz I wore it
and like every round I showed up and the
game was the minor focus as talking
about my hat was the main focus of each
game when I played it was the u.s.
championship one yeah yeah it was it was
quite something but well if you if
players out there if you want the
commentators to talk about you wear an
interesting piece of clothing like a hat
or you get a funny necklace or something
yeah well or you have funny hair I mean
talk to him his hair is the subject of
discussion every time now it's blue
before it was a little pink now before
it was purple the purple Tanya it's it's
the way to to attract attention from
commentators especially if they're
easily distracted
well we're still waiting on some of
these players to talk to we they have
not arrived as of yet hopefully we'll be
able to chat with them shortly but in
the meantime you know we're just looking
at the games were analyzing round 2 it's
in progress here at the norm Congress
yeah why don't we check out this game
between addy Patel and vanish borders so
this game was kind of weird I think
there was a time pressure phrase around
here let me go to a good point because I
don't want to go through the whole thing
necessarily ah yeah so they had this
point and I'm guessing it was time
pressure I don't know at some point I
kind of like damaged his position but
things became kind of weird played
rookie rookie - so I guess I guess why
it's up to pawns adding patellas as
white so that's a pretty big advantage
somehow I thought that black was going
to get the C pawn the eight pawns a
little weak but for some reason
something went wrong here so he played
94 for King the two pieces so far it
looks pretty reasonable Bishop h7 check
notice how g5 hangs with check but once
the King moves you have the fork to do
with and I don't think he wanted to mess
with that so he played the check rook e1
somehow he's just holding everything
together just barely the inertia plays
rook h8 looks like he's gonna win
material right Bishop d3 hitting this
rook so now if he played rook takes C
one if you play rook takes h5 I believe
he was worried about takes and now the
problem is if you take
pana rescuer okay
it's a skewer and stuff to tell it's
tough to tell only I'm bad at it don't
worry about it
so yeah Bishop and Knight attacks and
you're gonna lose it notice how the rook
placement on h5 is not ideal for helping
yourself out in these situations and
quite something so a lot of nice
resources found by addy rook takes c1
rook takes g5 check notice how if you
take back either rook you take the other
rook and Danish is simply up a piece
King f6 rook takes d5 this is the
problem when you're down lots of pawns
your opponent can afford to give back
material so now if you take this rook I
take this rook I'm just up a bunch of
pawns right plays Knight f3 check and
rook take c1 so looks like you know
blacks at least one in the exchange but
look at all these pawns White has three
pawns at the moon for the exchange and I
believe he won even more so
g4 he gives up a two which is not a very
meaningful pawn and they trade these
pawns and honestly I would say that
Danish has some minor drawing chances
but that's all they are I would say that
objectively this should be probably
winning for whites then they've made a
bunch of moves since then so let's let
me update this board and this is kind of
where we are so you can see that he
managed to hold on to this e6 pawn this
h6 pawn rolls and quite honestly I think
Danish is probably gonna resign
relatively soon because he has to move
his rook back to guard this and then the
King runs up and it's gonna be all she
wrote so a nice win by Adi who recovered
from a tough loss yesterday
indeed Eddie is sitting at two norms to
grandmaster norms the International
master himself Eddie Patel so yeah that
is a very nice win for him and his
ratings pretty close so I'd imagine if
he makes a norm here his breathing is
probably gonna cross so we could be
witnessing aji out in the making but of
course still a long way to go
one out of two is still a long way from
six and a half out of nine which is
he'd need so ratings 2478 just 22 points
to go yeah cross that threshold
fifteen-year-old Adi Patel could end up
being the story of this event could be
but remember he lost the first round so
one other two is just the beginning yes
he could go up he could go down you
could stay even ahead yes we should not
get ahead of ourselves but at the same
time it looks like he will get the wind
today with some nice resources because
it looked like Danish had his pieces in
trouble despite being down some pawns
but he found lots of nice tactics and
seemed to work out in his favor
I'm expecting a resignation relatively
soon so then again maybe I'm maybe he
has some crazy ideas looking at a bunch
of still mates yesterday so now I'm
looking for stalemate but I don't think
this time I were the king of these
things world's just did a funny hand
motion he just was like did one of these
things and what that was his move he
just saw Star Wars he's trying to you
see the forest on the keys I don't know
at some point you try everything you
know you get desperate enough you try to
do it whatever you can well you know
that plan didn't work
yeah I mean okay the game's updated a
little bit yeah I mean the King got in
as I said would happen and then now it's
just gonna be over at the moment you
can't just play King up because there's
checks but there's so many ways to win
this position one of the easiest is
actually just to play Bishop d5 put the
bishop on g8 and that's gonna be pretty
much the end so I'm suspecting that's
what he'll try but there are many ways
to win so it's really up to him how he
wants to finish the game but I suspect
he will finish it within a couple months
and they're moving quite rapidly now
yeah I would imagine it's gonna be hand
out pretty soon
I play there it is yeah yep so I think
he gave up that pawn and tried to check
on f6 but King moved back and down
judging from the look on the game so so
Adi Patel recovers and Boros gets
knocked back so they both have one other
two cuz Boros had a nice win yesterday
against October um and I thought that
was actually one of the few one-sided
couldn't go really either way games like
I thought he just played a really nice
game and won comfortably but a tough
loss for him today so in the GM norm
section how many how many games we have
left so in the GM norms section we have
I think that's all of them so we have
done yep so just to recap John
Bartholomew drew against Bronx off mark
perago beat Daniel gurevich Tata Abraham
Yun beat Akshay Chandra I understand we
have Stanley's like a look while we're
we have standings after two rounds have
been completed in the Grandmaster norm
section yes I'm not used to having such
visuals so for me I was reading him now
yes I don't have to say anything yes
very nice so so lucky new leading the
event with two out of two very very nice
result on her way to a GM norm again we
don't want to jinx anyone but looking
good there also of in para go to the
GM's half a point back everyone else a
lot of people on one and Korea which is
that zero out of two but I don't think
he's gonna stay there
too strong Claire yeah and you really
can't stress how how big of this this
early lead that Steph Willis toll Aikido
has one of the W GM's one of the last
seeds just by raiding yeah and now she's
in clear lead first place after just two
rounds you know but there's more games
to be played there's one more game
tonight and she have a clock indeed and
she played quite a game so I mean I
don't know she's got to be feeling good
about herself after beating one of those
top seeds with black and such crushing
faster she's got to be very confident
sometimes that can backfire depending on
the type of player but sometimes you can
really get her on a roll and if she gets
another win I'll tell you no one's gonna
want a player she's gonna be tough to
beat and how about the I am norm
sectional what's our status in round two
so our status there
so looking at those games so Jacobson
lost to Grove in ski as we said July a
Stearman is still playing against Justin
wing I believe Justin's gonna win this
game though that's just too many palms
we saw it before where he had this
position but after king c7 you can't
take what the rook is the key because
after rook takes King d7 you catch these
pawns you have way too many so you tried
ecigs but this a pawn as I mentioned is
just a strong pawn you can't ignore it
and it's tough this King is just a
little too close so you played check
King c6 rip back b5 r j8 King D 6 so now
this these pawns are gonna get taken
care of is just too much so I'm
suspecting that Justin is going to win
this game is black and get himself back
to 50% Matt Sankoh drew against call us
a nice result for Josh as we mentioned
Chi Yu as black drew against Torres
probably a result both of whom are ok
with that was the quickest game and
Jobin ama beat potential tour group the
oldest player in both events but who had
a nice position I thought that Joel got
a bit fortunate that you know he wasn't
punished a little good after the opening
but at the same time he took what was
given to him and truly played a bit too
aggressively but the only game still
going is this Justin Wayne game so this
is the last game and it looks like
Justin's gonna bring in the point
relatively soon the 12 year olds from
Katy Texas national master
Justin weighing yep 12 Rizzoli I think
your saya was laughing there about
something he kind of smiled at oh I'm
sorry well I can tell you that younger
players often have interesting board
habits I'm not I don't know we don't
have audio but you don't have audio
doing it could be anything you don't
know so all I know is there yeah younger
players just you know you don't have to
do any of this here you're already good
but tapping if it's a swivel chair chair
swiveling bottle crunching that's an
interesting that's a good one odd they
played more moves I should update the
board ah yeah so it was rookie Yates so
he took this pawn a7 going back and the
problem is that
in games or Josh but you don't really
need this pawn this F pawn is already
gonna get far the Kings cut them just
way too far away and that's as we know
is usually just the end of things like
tried to check but these checks of
course do nothing
rook g6 does absolutely nothing except
encourage the pawn forward I think it's
a matter of time so view designs usually
the only tries to bring the rip to the
first but now even if you just play f5
give a check give a check King h3 you go
behind and now your rook simply goes
behind note how this King is way too far
this King we're close to you to have
some drawing chances as it is this pawn
is just gonna run up the board for
example it takes you run attack the rook
f3 f2 game is pretty much over
not so many chances rook g6 certainly
doesn't help matters so Justin's
defending his be pawn I don't know if
that's something I would even bother
with but of course there's nothing wrong
with it and now what he can do is he can
move the King back put the pawn here
rook here this Kings cut off this guy's
defended King walks up also an easy way
to win it's kind of you know dealer's
choice in these positions you don't have
to win one way or another there are many
ways to bring home the point there are
many ways to get it done so it's kind of
a matter of taste no matter of how
sadistic one player is whether they want
to draw it out or win as quickly as
possible you don't know but anyway it
should be a pretty easy win for block
well see right here I'm looking at the
emotions on these players Justin when
they're on the right side of the camera
he is just it's confident as a 12 year
old can exude and Josiah Stearman is
clearly distraught he had his hands on
his head and laying back in a seat there
for a second but he's he's still playing
on I mean you know they're still
concentrating why not play on a few
moves there's a reputation Khattab for
being bad at names let's see if it's
true but I think that Justin's more than
competent enough to to get this one done
this one is just too many too many
things are wrong with white like way
it's way too many moves from the draw
usually it's a bad sign if you could
take off the b-pawn it's still a dead
loss that you know that things are not
so good but
anyway let's keep our board updated here
so how close do you think we are to
seeing a resignation here you think he's
gonna play it out um I mean I'd say he
might play it out a few moves to see if
you know he brings his king up he might
try to cut off the king but honestly
even if it's allowed you play f4 f5 and
the pawn starts running you have to run
back quickly before the pawn gets you
there are just too many things wrong
like you'd need you'd need black to make
a really bad move here to have a chance
and a bad move might be just hanging one
of the pawns
so it doesn't seem very likely the
players are putting down a lot of moves
here on the board there's not a lot of
choices to make so indeed not playing
toward the end yep they're going and I
suspect again you know especially kids
like they tend to play things out a
little longer
but I don't know there's nothing wrong
with it see if your opponent knows what
they're doing
it looks like Justin's Kenny king is
moving up the board he's showing more
confidence than I'd have upper rook
probably so he's he's on track I think
for his first win we might be able to
get a full screen shot of the players
there I mean we could see the board a
little bit better yeah there we go
yeah this boards not updating as fast as
the live camera will which should not be
surprising it's like those blitz
tournaments they're like we're not even
doing the digital but we're not even
bothering rated but it looks like
Justin's got it
Oh pinning the pawn look at this
trickery unfortunately it's easy to move
the King back and take care of things
which it looks like he'll do very
confident move Kings me yeah I think
that we're gonna get a resignation
fairly soon Justin has a sort of flair
to him you know it's hard to kind of put
into words
yeah he's shaking he's still the thing
is I find that when you're close to the
win even if you know you got it you
still feel a little nervous so you
always feel nervous until the hand
shoots out until you're done and then
you have the release of emotions no
matter how winning it is at least that's
my feeling and I think when you're a kid
it's even more true a couple of years
ago I I mean I'm not definitely not on
the level of these players but I
defeated my highest rated opponent and
it was clearly a 1 in game but I was
exactly yeah I've had this especially
when I'm playing like some of the
stronger GM's
beaten and it's like you get nervous
towards the end and it never goes away
the only thing you can do is control
help control your nerves really focus on
the position take your time not play too
quickly not play too slowly because
getting low on time can ruin your win
just kind of maintain that pace maintain
your nerves it takes some practice but
really that's what it comes down to
position like this it's kind of hard to
mess up but there are always ways you
can do it so it's like you spend you
know the game's over yeah yeah yeah so
Justin won the game so we can probably
pull up the standings of this section
pretty soon and we actually had a draw
in this section this time it was these
players they're getting they're getting
more draw we had two draws in this
section well how about that two draws in
this section I didn't think we'd have
two draws all tournament in this section
well let's take a look at the standings
indeed for the International master
norms section after the second round
yeah so we got Matt saenko still in the
lead but gave up a draw as white I'm
sure he's not super happy about that but
Josh Colossus is happy he's tied for the
lead still a long way for anyone to get
norms but they're on the right track
Luis Torres also drew against GU so
that's their only one zero point and
that's Brandon Jacobson but again
23:50 rated in this section kind of like
Daniel Goodrich in the top section I
don't see him staying at zero so we'll
see but and players have won their
tournaments can really go either way so
and for you fans watching on the
internet at us chess champs comm you
know that there is another round later
on tonight we're not going to be on the
air to cover it but we'll have the
results for tomorrow's broadcast at 2
p.m. now tonight we do have the pairings
for round 3 if we can take a look at 5
p.m. central for the Grandmaster dorm
what do you think of these these
matchups here Josh so I like a lot of
them um so Aikido is the one to watch
she's 2a no white against John
Bartholomew who's one of those slightly
lower rated players but obviously 24 50
or so very solid and I can tell you if I
played against John many times I've
always had a tough time beating him I
made me beat him once maybe twice but
honestly he's a tough guy to beat even
when he's playing badly he never
that badly he always keeps it solid so
you know again if she keeps her play she
might win that game but it's not gonna
be easy so I think that'll be a good one
to watch see if she can crack his
defenses
gorian h0 a tattoo is white against Tata
whose lowest rated in the section by a
lot but topped I've just got her win
we'll see if he can capitalize or if she
can keep her role going and Chandra
against Patel also Patel just got his
win Chandra just lost a tough one but
he's white he's gonna want to bounce
back so we have a lot of players who
some are on a roll some just lost the
top one and they're playing each other
so we'll see if the results could the
trend continues or if the players who
lost can bounce back his momentum a real
thing in chess Josh for sure and I would
say that depends on certain types of
players some players really rely on
momentum they get wins and they just get
more wins more wins a lot of players I
like that others sometimes suffer from
getting wins like they get too confident
I've definitely had this happen to me
where if I win a bunch of games I'm
actually more prone to lose not because
I'm playing a stronger player but just
because I'm a little too confident I
made me make decisions too easily I'm
not careful enough so I have to really
watch out for that whereas you if I lose
two or three games sometimes I mean I
don't lose that many in a row very often
but when it happens I'm actually playing
a little safer I might not get that win
but it's gonna be maybe tougher to beat
me than if I had won games
I remember this Korchnoi saying which
was excellent I lose one game it's tough
to beat me I lose two games it's almost
impossible to beat me if I lose three
games anyone can beat me apparently
there's a there's a line where you lose
so many you can just lose to anyone and
that can't happen if you're playing
really badly you can just lose to anyone
but as far as coming back some players
actually play well after a loss others a
loss really gets him down and they're
more vulnerable so it really depends on
the person might come er we used to tell
the stories during his lectures of when
he was at a tournament and he was paired
against a person who was definitely on
tilt they're not in a good way so that
played in his favor our second section
the International master norm tonight at
5:00 p.m.
round number three here are the pairings
that you will see tonight Justin Wang
and Erin grub in ski these are these
pairings here Josh what are your
thoughts so we have there are three
leaders even though this was the bloody
section if
there are three people tied for first
between colas Torres and Matt Cinco and
it's gonna be interesting because colas
is white against Torres are they gonna
play it safe and kind of maybe not
necessarily try to draw but not take too
many risks or as Torres really gonna
feel like he wants to win that game is
colas gonna really press hard I'm
interested to see that game might sink
oh is the other leader black against
Turgut who just lost a tough one is
Turgut gonna as you say go on tilt
probably not someone that experienced
but you know I'll be interested to see
that one as well and the top board
Justin wing if he can continue it to
continue his run going against Grove in
ski and what we'll see I mean it'll be
it'll be a tough one but lots of lots of
good games on both sides I think you
need and and while we await the results
of round number three this evening we'll
get ready to see you again tomorrow at 2
p.m. for round number four and remember
to check out the whole schedule the
prize fund the pairings the results it's
all on us chess champs calm so this
broadcast was produced by the world's
greatest B team Tami Hyde is our IT
adviser Isaac Krantz for sound and
graphics our technical director is danny
Machuca for Grand Master Josh Vidal my
name is Ben Simon we'll see you tomorrow
at 2 p.m. right here from st. Louis
until then so long from the Show Me
State
[Music]
you